let's take the video of falando casteels
death so that was shot by his his fiancé
and her readiness with her phone and her
quick instincts to use facebook alive
it's very was very potent in that video
people may remember that she is watching
her fiance bleed to death and at the
same time calling out to two entities to
witness her the first is God and the
second is facebook so she wants our
witness the purpose that we as users as
responsible users as humane users of the
internet have our responsibility is to
bear witness in that way not to
experience it ourselves so much as to
testify to the effect the fact that it
happened to serve as a massive jury of
peers who would who give credence to the
experience of other people and in that
way I think that was a an extremely
profound moment in the way crystallizing
the way that we all use facebook when we
use it right or use Twitter when we use
it right you know you have Newt Gingrich
even now saying we don't know white
white Americans don't understand the
experience of black Americans and that
chasm that gap in understanding has been
one that the internet is in large part
responsible for that there's a huge
vocabulary there's a set of symbols
there's you know what I think of as an
idiom set but also a testimony about
experience that we weren't that that of
each of each of us of each of us in
different dialects that we weren't
allowed or we we didn't have access to
communally share now we are as some
people say in this adolescents with this
with digital culture and we're trying to
determine what to do with this
infinitely polyglot culture speak so
many different languages you know I was
reading because why not I was reading
Henry James's account of being at Ellis
Island the begin
the last century and his horror at what
he calls the teeming and squirming
masses flooding on to into New York
which now we would see as politically
appalling as a level of disgust that
goes hand in hand with certain you know
antiseptic right-wing nativist thinking
especially coming from a waspy you know
Henry James figure mirrors almost
exactly the vocabulary that people use
when they describe Twitter when they
describe YouTube comments these people
are illiterate they're angry they're
squirming and teaming that is a natural
reaction to people who feel like they
belong here and there space is being
seized by people whose language they
don't speak who are you know in many
many ways alien to them but the internet
shows us over and over again and the
billions of us who use Facebook know
that that exposure is not only necessary
but good for us but good for us it's
exposing our immune system to test over
and over two different memes that
confront our bodies the way microbes do
and raise our immune system ask us to be
more robust citizens
you